[Music]
think
before we start i'd like to confirm
which committee members and officials
are here
i'm a muted apologies chair um if you
just give me one moment we just had
legal join the room so before we start
the feed
i'll just uh i'll just get them checked
in
apologies for that chair um martin can i
just confirm the live feed is on
thank you chair joining us for this
meeting of
planning committee are members of the
planning committee we have councillor
william armitage
jane barry andrew cooper peter elliott
mark foster heather leggett who is
substituting today
for councillor carol huckabee mo potts
alan powell tracy reader kathy rouse
diana roof yourself the chair of the
planning committee and ross shipman
um also with us today we have uh
councillor pat anchor who is observing
this meeting
richard purcell who is the head of
planning members of the planning team
members of the government's team
supporting the meeting and dream bills
and
form legal as well as members of the
public
who have registered to speak for this
meeting thank you chair
thank you as you all know we have a
protocol in place for meetings in this
virtual way which i would now like the
meeting facilitator to read out
thank you chair so this is a reminder to
all members to
address and behave as you would do if we
were in person in the council chamber in
accordance with
the council's adopted virtual meeting
etiquette please be aware that this
meeting
is recorded and it is being live
streamed
um please could you speak through the
chair remaining muted when invited
when not invited to speak and if you do
wish to indicate to speak you can either
raise your hand or write speak in the
chat
before bar and we will make sure that
the chica is able to see that if the
chair is unable to see
your indication to speak um the team
today will be assisting her
in order to be able to do that when you
speak if you would kindly introduce
yourself
um and state the ward in which you
represent
we'll be conducting voting today on roll
call for each
application please be mindful of your
home surroundings and appear alone
always
when on camera and keep yourself on
camera at all times where possible
thank you chair thank you
item one on today's agenda is apologies
for absence
okay there are two apologies received
today uh one from
councillor jackie ridgeway and the other
from
councillor carol huckabee who is
substituted today by councillor heavenly
thank you and i take it from everyone's
attendance there aren't any other
apologies
on receive chair thank you the second
item is declaration of interest have any
been read
i mean members are requested to declare
the existence and nature of any diplo
disclosely drew new interest and or
other interests
not already on their register of
interest in any item on the agenda and
withdraw from the meeting at the
appropriate time
have we received any declaration of
interest
uh non-received chair thank you
do any members have any interest to
declare at this present
point in time
no indications from memphis chair thank
you
item three minutes of the last meeting
as you know the minutes of our meeting
held on tuesday the 9th of february
2020.
are we all happy that they are a correct
record
move them chair i'll second them
thank you all those in favour
chair i just wanted to speak before they
were moved
okay tracy carry on am i all right too
yeah yep feel free and it was just with
regards to the ridgeway application
um sort of page nine page ten of the
report
um chair i know we don't keep a bait and
um minutes i i'm aware of that
but i just felt obviously reading over
it and that they're just sort of too
generic
and obviously i had raised concerns and
obviously i believe
councillor cooper had also raised
concerns about this
application going against um officers
recommendations
i can't speak for councillor cooper but
certainly for myself
i would have preferred my concerns to
have been sort of noted a bit more in
there
into the report so i'm just asking chair
would i be able to have
my concerns recorded in those minutes
please
i think that i can't see a problem with
that
alan i think what we would do in these
circumstances chair is to say that the
minutes were approved
subject to clarification that uh
councillor reader
had expressed these concerns about the
ridgeway application
thank you are you happy with that
council reader
thank you okay
so we all have all those in favor go
back to that now
fine thank you any against
any abstentions thank you
that moves us on to the main business of
today as you can see we only have two
applications
each of which has its own report marked
as item
four and five and happy with this and
intend to consider them
in that order however before we do this
i would like
the clerk to explain for the benefit of
members speakers and the public who are
watching
on youtube how they will be dealt with
right thank you chair uh this is the
procedure for considering applications
at the meeting
we will consider the two applications in
the order that they are set out on the
agenda
the chair will introduce the application
then ask the planning officers
to refer members to any late comments or
updates received
since the agenda was issued the late
items agenda supplement
has probably has been published on the
council's website
and the link has been sent to committee
members
the planning officers will then give a
brief presentation
setting out the application plans and
photographs from the site
the screen showing this presentation
will be shared with those attending the
meeting
they can also be seen on the council's
website through its youtube channel
following on from this the chair will
ask each of the speakers
any ward members first followed by
objectors then the applicant or their
agent
to speak to the committee each speaker
will have three minutes to put forward
their views
using this conferencing facility
there will be a reminder given by the
clerk when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the speaker's three
minutes members of the committee will
have an opportunity to ask the speaker
questions
if necessary to clarify any
points which they have made when we have
heard from all the speakers on an
application
the chair will open up the meeting for
debate by the committee
and determination by a vote
a note for speakers once the application
you've come to speak on has been dealt
with
you may leave the virtual meeting room
if you choose to remain then please mute
your microphone
and turn off your camera you will not be
allowed to participate further in the
meeting
from that point as you are aware this
meeting is being live streamed
the council will make a recording for
the purpose of preparing the minutes
once the minutes have been approved by
the committee then this recording will
be deleted
please note that others may also record
the live stream
from the internet thank you chair
thank you we'll move on to the first
application which is item
four and this is ned forward slash
20 forward slash zero zero eight three
three
forward slash foih this is the retention
of the existing root line to
250 ml higher than a approved
planning application eighteen four
stroke
zero zero zero nine forward slash flh
and the relocation of an office studio
in the front garden
at britain main road cup thorpe in line
of our normal practice i'm going to ask
the planning officers to tell us about
any late comments reports that have been
produced and for the planning manager
to give a brief presentation showing us
photos of the plans on site
the meeting facilitator will share the
presentation on screen
this my i might find it difficult to see
anybody
and everybody therefore i will allow the
officers to complete their presentation
first i ask members to reserve any
points of order or questions about the
process
until the end of the presentation
there's plenty of time for any questions
later
thank you richard are you
leading on this one
good afternoon jay yes i'll i'll take
the lead on this one
so you see this application
on the screen here for
the proposal to increase the
roof line of the
extensions and changes to
this property by 250 mil
and also to site an office pod
in um close to the front boundary
of the site so
this is the site on the uh on the corner
in cut thor
um and the the um
the proposal has uh which
i'll go through the history shortly but
the extensions are
i'll say to the to the house around here
and the
office pod is moving from this point
here
down to the the front corner of the site
so the main changes uh the
the main issue is the difference you'll
see here
so we have the
um
difference being the
ground level there or the floor level on
the ground floor
and as the development has taken place
there have been various changes along
the way
due to a number of uh factors
and i'll go through what those are later
when i go through the planet history but
the
issue for today is the
difference that this 2
150 ml makes uh in terms of
residential amenity and the appearance
in the um in the street scene
so the plan in history is that
uh early in 2018
this was the scheme that was approved
and you'll see that we have
uh basically roof lights felix windows
in the
roof there and when it comes to the
first floor
balcony area this is the screen
arrangement we have here
also slightly different uh changes to
the fenestrations
later in 2018
the scheme came forward with the
um with dormer windows
in the roof and
a higher wall for screening on that
first floor balcony
later as uh will be explained i'm sure
in full by the
um the agent later
the um
[Music]
the door windows
were where the roof the ridge
of the door was in the plane
of the roof the normal windows
were approved again retrospectively
so that the ridge ran into the ridge of
the roof
so all these are matters that have been
approved
and so the only issue relating to
today's application relation to the
house
is the additional 250
millimeters of hype
so that's um as we see
the uh the the scheme has finished
and that's as we see it with the
um this patio area here
is roughly the area where the um the
office pod
previously stood
this is the area down the left-hand side
of the of the house and
showing the closest proximity to the
neighboring uh
house and that's it looking from the
other direction
you can just see in the
top left there's the
uh the the grille of the um
uh the open um
edge of the first floor balcony which is
which you'll see
there at the back
the office pod excuse me
you see here and on the right hand side
here is the
the boundary to to the road
a bit closer and
this on the left hand side is the
boundary to
the um so the large house
and our background on the
the other side of the of the house
looking at that pod from the street
you can just about see the roof and
the the building through the trees there
you can just see the roof
and the end of the building there
so just looking up at the street scene
this is the the next few pictures you'll
see are taken from the road
along here
so this is the
um the house
with the uh finished views you see quite
a large um
uh house in the in the background there
which is the other
neighbor on the other side
you can see clearly there the um of the
dormers
going into the ridge of the house and
the question here is whether
the extra course to all intents and
purposes of the stone
there plus a little bit more a few cents
a couple of cents about five centimeters
more
really would make a sense of the area
or two residential amenity
from this view you can see
the the roof against the back
of the the house behind and similarly so
there
and there
so the the application was called to
committee
um by the ward council council of fatca
so that you could the view the members
could view
the situation in relation to the uh the
appearance of the pod
um and you'll see that's the
uh from the representations made there's
no
um objections to the to the pod in
causing harm to
residential amenity or to the street
scene
and the the the um
the other shows that say is the is the
one of
whether the um building
at 250 mil higher causes any harm to
planning interests
let's finish the president's age
thank you richard i'm now going to
invite speakers to speak as the clerk
explained they will each have three
minutes
to go over their points they will be
informed when 30 seconds remain
as members you can ask them to clarify
any matters that have been raised
remember your question should only
relate to the points which have already
been made
if the technology fails us we have asked
them to send us in advance the written
statement of their comments
those that we have received have been
included in the agenda supplement
i have two speakers to my knowledge on
this application
and the first one is an objector john
robinson
mr robinson are you with us
yes i'm here thank you you have three
minutes when you're ready
good afternoon chair and members of the
committee had a lot of experience in
dealing planning applications
receiving many briefing papers to be
studied
something i've experienced some time ago
as a member of the derbyshire county
council planning committee
i therefore intend to emphasize certain
sailing points to assist
you on breaching your decision i spent
time in studying the ministry of
housing's planning act definitions from
the act
i will refer to enforcement and when
there has been a breach of planning
control
defined as carrying out a development
without the required planning permission
effective enforcement is important too
one
tackle breaches of planning control
which would otherwise have
an acceptable impact on the immunity of
the area
two maintain the integrity of the
decision-making process
three help ensure the public acceptance
of the decision-making process is
maintained
now for some facts firstly evidence
showed better
have been built higher than approved
after many weeks of letters meetings
submission of photographic evidence
disputed by the applicant's agent
finally
on august the 15th of 2019 i received a
letter from the head of planning
that the height to the east was higher
than approved plans
corroborating our original claim thus
a breach of planning control secondly
there are on record 14 complaints and
objections
recorded from nearby nether neighbors a
petition of over a hundred signatures
stating alterations were detrimental to
the neighbors
and did not sit well within the villages
landscape
part of the parish council letter
objection which i hope you have read
states
it it particularly irks because other
nearby net residents have had
applications refused
where they have sought approval to raise
their roof height the council is most
concerned that this application is
allowed
it will set a dangerous precedent this
allows evidence to rise roughshod
over planning worlds regulations time
and time again
whatever comes comes in these objections
it is the apparent inconsistency of the
department
particularly in regard to roof heights
thirdly i would like to point out
that the council has precedent in
requiring reconstructions
this was the case some years ago 30
seconds from maine
well they green barlow i conclude
if you approve this application ask
yourselves
are we being consistent are we meeting
the minister's recommendation
thank you thank you mr robinson
are there any questions for the speaker
i can't answer questions thank you mr
robinson
next speaker for this application is the
agent
and new jenkins mr jenkins i can see you
on screen
are you ready three minutes when you are
yeah thank you chair uh this application
is to consider two issues
the minimum increase in the property
ridge eye and the retention of a home
office pod situated in the front
domestic garden area
the property has the benefit of planning
consents to raise the roof fight to
create a first floor extension
along with the further consent to form
dome windows in the roof space
the issue is whether the raising of the
ridge art by 250 millimeters has a
detrimental effect on the location and
neighboring properties
the roof design is of a hip construction
which reduces the overall impact and
results in a short length of ridge
which has been raised by 250 millimeters
above the original consented scheme
there have been complaints that
neighboring properties in the past have
been refused permission to raise the eye
to their dwellings
however times and policies change and
permitted development legislation now
encourages the raising of dwellings to
maximise accommodation without utilizing
further land
brampton parish council have raised an
objection on the basis they
do not understand how it just finished
250 millimeters higher than approved
we provided a detailed section an
explanation
which clearly sets out the series of
events which resulted in incremental
increases through the stages of
construction
accumulating in the overall increase of
250 millimeters
this is documented in full in the
committee report there's never been any
intention to ride roughshod or break
rules and regulations as
insinuated all changes to the building
have been the subject of planning
applications and
subsequent approvals this minor inc
increasing night due to construction
practicalities was not carried out to
benefit the applicant
and presents no real increased detriment
to other properties
the newly constructed dwelling adjacent
the subject property has a ridge eye
higher than the applicants it is agreed
by planning officers
that there will be a barely perceptive
impact
very difficult to know any meaningful
change and the proposal has no
unacceptable impact on the character of
the area
the other subject of consideration is
the home office situated in the garden
the office has been present in the front
garden for a number of years
prior to the property being purchased by
the applicant three years ago
working from home to 12 months is
strongly encouraged
the office will be limited to use only
by the occupants of the dwelling
the applicant has repositioned it in a
location which is concealed in the fork
of two mature edge rows
given the fact that it has remained in
the front garden for a number of years
without
issue the applicant was genuinely
unaware that the re-site
would require planning consent 30
seconds remain
all be situated closer to the highway it
presents no real
impact on the character of the area and
the bordering edge roads are mature and
are to be
retained thank you chair
thank you are there any questions for mr
jenkins
councillor elliot councillor armitage
thank you chair uh you mentioned another
property you've got to reject
higher than betron which property would
that be sir
that's the one that's situated um
looking at veteran from the road the
property to the right
the newly built property right on the
corner
that reached number 52.
that's right that yeah i think you'd
probably agree with me that that's in a
much more elevated position so
it's ridiculous likely to be higher well
then it's elevated then the region i
desire yes so it's elevated so it
forms the back cloth as you could
clearly see from the photograph so
uh that i'd have to obviously if the if
the
underside of the ridges are here thank
you
councillor armitage
uh thank you chair uh yeah i'd just like
to i mean
you're given all the reasons why uh the
ridge height
is higher uh and all the rest of it
i mean surely as an agent uh and the
architect as well
should have realized this when they were
actually when you were actually building
it
and he could have then come to us and
said
we've got a problem here uh stop the
building and
uh because we have to increase the rich
height
i mean uh i presume you're an educated
person
and you can you would have realized that
the rich height was going to be higher
than you'd already got planning
permission would i be
right well no we
um these were all as i said the
incremental increases there was not one
issue there there was uh we would we did
want the property to be
replaced in natural stone uh which
which was of course an issue and these
are these are things of you know
75 million 50 mil there um
i think with planning drawings uh
and then leading on to construction
drawings i think there will always be
uh some practicalities and and i think
if
every building was checked to that
degree um
it was very difficult for for them to be
uh
exactly the level as shown on on on
planning drawings
um the uh the the
incremental increases were barely
noticeable at the time
and certain construction issues uh
required
uh stronger thicker materials floor
joists
uh the roof trusses which are designed
you know at a later stage of the
building regulation
um process so
uh we genuinely were not aware that the
ridge eye
was uh was any iron until it was checked
electronically and
i get very difficult just to look at a
ridge eye
and judge the from the ground that
that's 250 mil
higher with all respect i don't think
that's possible
yes but uh if i could come back to you i
mean surely
you realize when you were actually
taking the roof off
of a bungalow that the uh
actual uh spans had to be far deeper
to carry the weight and uh
you know i would have thought that at
that point you should have realized
that the whole lot was going to be much
higher
and i you know personally i think it's
it's negligent on be on behalf of
all all of the team con concerned that
uh
yeah you'd never notice this all right
you've got
increments but building regulations are
building regulations
and uh and they're the same regulations
that you had before
yeah i would accept that but these are
increases which
as i say are um
are part of the construction process
we're not there
every minute of the day to see that uh
that in effect you know we submit the
drawings and
they are built according to those
drawings
of what's happened on site is uh is
they have made changes accepted uh small
changes but
incrementally resulting in the 250 mil
so we're you know we certainly obtain
the planning consent obtain the billing
rates consent
but we we don't have the control over um
everything uh on site that happens and
these were genuine
issues which made the uh i think made
the project work better and the overall
result is um is an increase of 250 ml we
we
we're not disputing that that's that's
how the thing is finished up practically
and i think probably a major issue is
that the
the type of roof is it's not a gabled
roof where you've got an excessive ridge
length
it's a hit roof which
[Music]
impacts less on on uh adjacent
properties and results in
in a very short ridge line which is uh
which is where the the increment is
well uh i i don't really uh accept what
you're saying
uh as such uh perhaps you can explain
how the uh pod was moved without
permission
i mean uh did it you sort of spring up
later down uh across the uh
the paddock to wait where it is at the
moment i mean
why was that moon it seemed odd
the owner of the property moved into
what he considered to be
a better position it's tucked away can't
be seen
um i we personally as agents
were not responsible for that that was
what the
um the the owner of the property uh
moved the uh move the pod it's an
existing pod that had been there a long
time
and uh they they genuinely were not
aware that there was any consent
required to
recite that uh that office pod
so we we had no involvement in that
whatsoever that's something the
uh uh the owner of the property
um took upon himself to
to move it to a position which you felt
was more discreet
right thank you thank you councillor
rouse then councillor foster
good afternoon mr jenkins just a quick
question really
for me i'm just wondering why
didn't you put the dormer windows in the
plane of the roof
rather than going up to the ridge
why didn't we in the plane of the roof
yeah normally you wouldn't normally see
a dormer on a ridge would you
it's normally below that ridge it was it
was it was a
the sili on the dormers were very low um
the client asked us if he could lift
those up he's a player room he's got
young children and he asked if we could
lift the silhouette
now lifting the sili doesn't have any
real impact on
uh on the visual impact from it the you
know the visual impact is from the eye
line
um and the client asked us if uh
if that was possible and we made the
application
on the basis that he was concerned about
the eye to the sill
um and that was approved so that that
really was
the reason okay thank you
councillor foster uh thank you chair uh
mark foster member for call austin uh
hello mr jenkins
uh just a bit of clarity for me please
uh we've got the 250 mil which is the
ridge height
and then earlier um we had our officer
mention
one course i'm not sure if that's a type
of stone course
or not i'm not sure so uh we've got the
250 mil
for the ridge high if that's also at the
gutter
all right where the pan sits uh that 250
ml
as well yeah that keeps the same angle
of the roof so is it still there because
that would be three course of bricks and
not one course of bricks
it's it's only a small point but just a
bit of clarity on that whether it's at
the uh
the final course or it's also the 250 at
the virginia as well
please well yeah there's a course of
stone which is
is actually 150 and then um
there's a as i said an incremental
increase
in the the final design of the roof
trusses
which uh are an engineered truss and uh
i think
probably something like 75 mil increase
in those
and uh and uh 50 mil increase when
at the uh the first floor levels where
the
new joists were the the stronger the
deeper joists were inserted so it's an
addition
of of all those different heights that
total 250 which is why we commissioned
the um uh the electronic survey to
to actually uh measure
exactly what that ridge eye came out at
and
that was an independent survey the
floor level has not changed obviously
because that was the old
bungalow floor level so we're able to
check from the
existing floor level to the ridge eye
on a gps survey and and that's where the
the increase is and further to that mr
jenkins
no no i understand it and now i've had
it explained um
so further to that uh what about the the
top floor level
so that the upper floor of the building
is that any higher than the original
plans
the uh well the wall plate level will be
the floor level uh the floor level will
be approximately
100 millimeter 150 maximum higher at the
floor level because the
bottom corner of trust is is slightly
deeper yeah
yeah that that's a yeah it would be fair
to say there's a
there is a small increase in the in the
first floor level yeah or
the attic level yes yeah that makes
sense now and it's
it's it just points me away from it's
just how it's finished up
because that's by design that's how it
looks to me anyway so
but thanks mr jenkins
are there any further questions
counselor parts
thank you chair um mo parts i'm the
killer marsh counselor mr jenkins hello
um i i just wanted to my question
relates to the sighting of the pod it
looking at the pictures that hedge
looked like it was
uh conifer all the way down um i suppose
what i'm getting at here is
is there gonna be all year round cover
for that pod
located so close to the uh to the
pathway
well it is um it is primarily an another
green edge that
there are some native species in there
but
uh primarily it is um
it is an evergreen edge i think you know
it would not be showing
as it is at the moment at this time of
year if that was not the case so
it's a you know it's a substantial edge
um
the applicant is is comfortable with
that
being retained and conditioned if if
that
needs to be conditioned for the
protection then that's not an issue at
all now
i mean they want the privacy obviously
and uh
it's uh an area of the garden which they
genuinely felt was
was the right sighting for it tucked
away in there
thank you yeah i can see it would be
from their point of view in the house
it's
it's the furthest point it could be but
in terms of its proximity to the
to the highway um if that hedge wasn't
there
it would be it would be very visible um
but thank you thank you for that
thank you are there no further questions
for mr jenkins
thank you mr jenkins
okay members we now have the opportunity
to ask any questions to the planning
officer
councillor armitage
uh thank you can you tell me
uh what defines this uh
pod uh i mean if it was a garden
shed it wouldn't need planning
permission what's this
definition why does the pod need uh
planning permission well
it doesn't look like a permanent uh
structure
could you enlighten me please on this
yep let's say um
it's as permanent as is necessary to
need
a permission the reason it needs a
permission in this instance is because
of its proximity to the road it's um
that's that's the that's the reason why
it needs a consent i mean if this was in
the
back garden it would be a different
set of circumstances
it is a building which will be
considered as
ancillary to the the main dwelling
um although it's going to be used as an
office it is
um the the office uh as might well be a
room
in the house being used as an office um
it's not going to be a separate um
business or a separate uh um the use in
planning terms
so it only needs permission um by virtue
of its proximity
to the highway so when it was in its
original position
i presume then that it never had
planning permission would it be right
um i i don't think it did have uh any
planning permission no um how long it's
been there i
i don't know right
so basically it's uh what sort of
distance are we looking at that
that it needs to be clear of the road
um it's uh i
remember who calls it's about 20 meters
from from the highway
um but when it's in the
in the front of the uh in front of the
dwelling so
if you've got a very large garden
it can still be in the front of the
the house provided it's more than 20
meters away from the
um from the highway but as you see here
i mean this is
pretty much about a meter or so away
from the highway boundary so there's no
question about
thank you councillor elliot
thank you chair um yes question question
to richard please
i have to say richard it is an
application that i stood and spoke about
and i never really wanted it to go
through the house
uh i was quite happy with it as a dormer
bungalow but the application was voted
through by
by my colleagues
and now so we've got to live with it and
it has caused a lot of uh
issues within the village uh i'm the i'm
the member of cut for cut form
uh and 250 mil in fairness now it's up
won't make a great deal of difference
uh and as it's been approved the whole
way through
i i've got nowhere to go with it um
the pod is is elevated from the road and
it is screened from the road with the
conifers
i've not really got an issue with that i
have got an issue with what it brings
with it
and that's the lighting within the
within the boundaries i don't know if we
can do anything about that because it's
lit up like a christmas tree most nights
i've had quite a few complaints about
that and
uh similarly the parking that it
attracts
every single morning every single night
half on the path
half on the road on a sharp bend with
people walking up into to and from
school with push chairs
and push bikes and all the rigmarole
rigmarole that goes with it
i don't know if you know if this is
minded to go through whether or not we
can condition all that
because the parking is shocking
okay um well firstly
um we we can't control
um parking on the highway uh through
planning
uh conditions or even parking part on
the um the footpath and part on the
highway
what we can say is that within
the cartilage of the house you would
have seen from one or two of the
photographs
there is a a wide drive area
um large turning area and um
so that there should be uh sufficient
car parking
in in there for for any um
people who you know who are living there
but
the the issue i'd say is that
um this pod is as i mentioned earlier
ancillary to the main use of this as a
dwelling
um if this is if this office
uh use is generating uh a lot of
visitors that starts to change the
characteristic
of uh this property as a residential
property
then we very well need to consider
whether it is
a a change of use to
a residential and office use but that's
not the situation
that's been applied for it's not the
situation that
has been asked for but it is a situation
that we will
um i'm sure presidents will continue to
monitor and
um you know if there is a change in that
characteristic we will review
that situation but it is very much a
separate situation
so that is with the committee for a
decision today
thanks richard
thank you if there's no further
questions i'm going to ask
the clerk to explain the next part which
is about
the motions and how they go forward
thank you
yes thank you chair uh please bear in
mind members
that a motion must be moved and seconded
before a vote is taken
if an amendment to a motion is moved and
seconded
then that amendment will be voted on
first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against officer recommendations
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reasons for moving a motion against
officer recommendations
should comprise the relevant planning
issues and to be supported by evidence
as necessary if a motion to reject
officer recommendation fails
or in other words it is not passed that
doesn't mean that the recommendations
are automatically approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision
through a further motion in favor of the
recommendations
or another course of action this will
need to be approved by the committee
through another vote
in terms of the timings of the motions
these should be moved and seconded after
the committee has heard read and
discussed the evidence before it
the chair will indicate when this point
has been reached
and will then invite motions to be put
when members will be reminded of this by
the clerk if they wish to propose a
motion before then
thank you chair thank you
i shall open the floor for debate if
anyone wants
to lead that
counsellor shipment um
yeah i'm gonna say i'm part of me thinks
why hasn't even come here
the other part of me i'm just like yeah
okay
we should we need better enforcement we
need to make sure that
people are building to the suspects that
we've approved or previous
um bank committees have approved but
ultimately the assets 25 centimeters
taller
i don't think it's going to make a
significant impact if
it retains um the the
the stuff of the roof as it is
in terms of this pod the fact that it
doesn't require planet permission if
it's further away from road and it's
screened from the road
for me it's not an issue as long as it
is screened
then i don't see why we can reject this
i just think that we need to just get
this passed and then move on to
the next piece of business
thank you councillor any further
councillor hermitage
yes uh i mean it's obvious to me
that uh we've had uh
different height increments put in all
the way through
and it was uh finished originally
we're looking at uh 400 millimeters
higher
well you know it stands to reason that
if you jack the floor up uh it's going
to be less
but it's gone on and on and on
being higher and higher all the way
through and it should have been
seen to earlier but anyway that's it
we've
ended up but it's maybe 10 inches higher
which is
well basically uh neither in or there
uh the other thing is about this
pod now it's bounded by lei landy hedge
they have limited lives uh these lay
landi
and the problem is with them uh is
that they've got this moth that appears
very frequently it'll kill the hedge off
very quickly uh with not much warning
i would like to put a condition that
they put
a substantial sort of wooden uh
thing to stop the light going through
and things like that
and i would like that as a condition if
we are
going to pass this uh i feel it's a
retrospective i don't like
retrospective uh planning applications
myself
but if it were to go to appeal i'm
afraid
the applicant would probably win
thank you councillor councillor barry
yes yeah i was actually just going to
move officer's recommendations
are there any other comments
no okay a counselor elliot chair
oh councillor elliot sorry thank you
chair uh
yes through through the chair um council
armitage has just said he'd like to see
it screen differently with uh
with a fence or something i personally
wouldn't
because it's in an elevated position
anyway at least when it's
when it's hidden with greenery or
vegetation
it is hidden and it does blend in better
there are no
there are no fences two and three and
four meters high anywhere up that road
i take his point completely about the
screening
and yes it needs to remain screened but
but not in the fashion of a anymore
structure otherwise you may as well
put the pod on the side of the wall so
that's just uh that's just the side to
that but i agree with his conditioning
of the screening
okay go along with that peter
thank you yeah going along with
with that the screening i think a
condition could be put in that it's
it is screened by trees whichever the
trees may be but put a condition in that
it has to remain
screened at all times um with a
preferably um trees that are native to
the area
rather than the la la la la la lander
okay is everybody happy with that
nothing else to say well i shall open it
for motions and having heard
everything and everyone's read today and
the officers recommendations before us
what is the view of the committee on the
application i am now
opening the floor for a motion thank you
to go uh with officers recommendation
and approve this
uh application but with uh
the conditions which we've mentioned
for the screening thank you is there a
second
second that chair but obviously with the
the conditions as well as
council armitage said um and obviously
with what council barry was saying about
screening with trees
so keeping it very natural and it fits
in with climate change agenda as well
and so yeah thank you chasey
richard yeah um i just want to see
clarification before a resolution is
passed
with an additional condition relating to
screening
you've seen the photographs as they are
showing
the the pod from the street
and there is a lot of screening there
already
if you are wanting to see screening
there
which is of an indigenous species
the way to do that would be basically to
take away
all the laylandi that is in there now
and to plant a hedge of an indigenous
species
so for the next however many years
that pod will be seen
far more obviously from the street
whilst the uh indigenous species are um
are growing up to a height to be able to
screen it
so you might want to give certain
thoughts to that if that's what you're
intending to do
that's going to be one of the
consequences of that
richard from what i understood from the
debate and people will correct me if i'm
wrong
they're happy with villandai to stay now
but should the land die get diseased or
be removed
they should only be replaced by natural
habitation mature shrubbery mature trees
of similar ilk so it is screened from
the road
i can see lots of heads nodding up and
down so i think i'm on the right way
yeah okay now that's that's fine i've
got the clarification for word
of such a condition you can plant it
in front between the between the pod uh
and the leland eye and when they get to
uh matu when the lip that and they'll
give this the
hedge the new hedge time to grow so
if if you plant it together uh next to
the
land right that'll be the best way of
doing it so
there's always a hedge there
through the chair chair that that is
pretty much about it what
council armitages has just said the
delay landing right now do
screen it because they've been uh
they've been
positioned to do just that but if that
was
to disappear all you would see is the
the pod and the rest of the garden and
the rest of the lighting that's
quite offensive so it needs to be a
permanent
screen i'm all for planting in between
it plant more
i don't i don't care which way that runs
around with
as you rightly say you know native
species but if you go
down cutthroat road there's everything
you could
possibly wish to see going up and down
there
from aces to everything you there's
plenty of stuff up there
okay thank you so i think we're all
happy with the condition that it should
be
native or mature some form of
natural hedging so it's study chair to
approve officer recommendations subject
to the additional
condition that there should be always
appropriate screening
which would transition to um screening
of natural
or rather indigenous vegetation is that
the essence of it members
i'm happy with that everybody happy with
that yes see lots of nodding heads
that's fine alan
okay thank you chair we'll move it to
the vote
thank you chair and members um the vote
will be conducted by roll call if you
could clearly say
for against or abstain to grant
permission with the conditions
discussed counselor armitage
how's barry full counselor cooper
or casa elliott
councillor powell four
cancer reader four
has a ralph's four
council rough four
and cancer shipment oh
chair that's 12-4 um unanimously carried
thank you we now have a motion and
that's all been passed so thank you very
much for
for that we'll move on to the next
application
[Music]
i've just lost my piece of paper i've
got that much stuff here
one second here we go second application
is for ned forward slash
two zero four slash zero one one three
seven forward slash
fl demolition of existing buildings and
conversions of existing buildings
formerly used in association with livery
and riding school to form single
dwelling restoration and retention
of auxiliary buildings erection of four
new dwellings
with associated landscaping parking and
accessories
the setting is of a listed building
affecting a public right-of-way
at cartilage hall farm homes field for
mr matthew jeckins
so okay everybody i'm going to open this
to
the planning officer richard are you
leading on this
um it's going to be me myself um sorry
yes thank you chair it's going to be me
to take you through the presentation for
this one sorry to
interrupt there and
just before um commencing the
presentation i just wanted to summarize
the policy context and the
officer conclusions and the application
site situated partially within the green
belt
and the cartilage conservation area the
site is a former equestrian use
excuse me and comprises previously
developed land as per the definition
included in the mppf
officers consider that the proposals
would have a greater impact on the
openness of the green belt than the
existing situation
particularly in visual terms in this
regard the proposed development is not
considered to comply with the defined
policy exceptions to an appropriate
development in the green belt
were also of the view that the
post-detached dwellings and the southern
elements of the site
would result in some harm to the
character and appearance of the
conservation area
by virtue of their scale and massing as
set out in the officer report however
is considered the identified harm has
been reduced from that of the scheme
previously refused
which members may be may recall from the
june planning committee of last year
namely the harm has been reduced as a
consequence of the
revised design and scale of the proposed
dwellings
as with the previous scheme the harm
identified is considered to be less than
substantial in policy terms
officers consider that despite the harm
identified the proposals would represent
comprehensive redevelopment of the
entire site
refurbishing and retaining all the
historic farm buildings and the dry
stone boundary walls within the
application site
as such in this instance the less than
substantial harm caused by the massing
and scale of the new buildings
is considered to be outweighed by the
public benefits
arising by way of saving this important
historic farm group
and securing an optimum viable use in
accordance with paragraph 196 of the
mppf
moreover the identified public benefits
are considered to amount to very special
circumstances
that would outweigh the harm identified
in greenbelt terms
as set out in the office reports
officers are at the viewing
that subject to conditions there are no
technical reasons that would warrant
refusal of the application
on balance in view of these
considerations officers consider the
proposal
to represent an acceptable form of
development in accordance
with the applicable local plan and mppf
policies
um if we can move on to the slides
please nikki i'll run through the
presentation
so the first slide shows the collection
of buildings forming the application
site and its surroundings
the site is broadly highlighted in
yellow
to the south of the site is open
countryside
and to the north northwest of the site
are buildings within the defiant
settlement of homes fields
approximately 50 meters to the north of
the site lies cartilage grange
which is a range of great great zoo
listed building
beyond which lies cartilage hall a grade
two star listed building with associated
grade two listed buildings within its
grounds
um if we can move on to the next slide
please nikki
um slide two so this sets out the layout
plan as proposed
this illustrates the proposed new
dwelling situated around an informal
courtyard arrangement
the plan also shows the existing the
existing historic farm buildings that
the scheme seeks to retain by way of
conversion to domestic uses
including the threshing barn to this to
the east of the access track
um as you can see this on the plan this
is the most southeasterly building on
the plan
um dotted lines show the proposed
footprint of the dwellings proposed
under the previously refused scheme
to illustrate the amendments as regards
the footprint of those buildings um
you might be able to just make those out
on the plan um
for the four new dwellings um if we can
move on to the next slide please
um this is the proposed parking
arrangements for within the site
um two spaces are earmarked for the
existing farmhouse
which falls outside the application site
three spaces are proposed for the
threshing barn
um and a further three spaces for the
dwelling adjacent to the threshing barn
two spaces are proposed for the dwelling
to the
southwestern corner of the site and
if further space is proposed for each of
the
semi-detached dwellings so each of those
properties will comprise one parking
space
if we can move on to the next slide
please nikki
this is the elevational drawings for the
proposed conversion of the threshing
barn which broadly details the external
works involved in the conversion
of the building to a dwelling house
next slide please
again elevational drawings but these are
for the semi detached dwellings proposed
the dwellings will comprise natural
stone walling materials
with the previously applied for metal
cladding treatment on upper floors
emitted from the scheme
next slide please
this is the elevational drawing for the
detached dwelling in the southwestern
corner of the site
similarly the um materials have been
altered
in in the way described for the previous
slide
um and next slide please
and similarly um elevational drawings
for the detached dwelling between the
two aforementioned properties um
a subsequent plan will illustrate the
extent to which these
revised properties have been reduced in
scale and
next the next slide please in fact this
is the um
the slide here which is a sectional
drawing which um
illustrates a comparison of the scale
and massing of the previously refused
scheme with the revised scheme
as you can see on the plan the areas
edged in red
reflect the scale and massing of the
previously uh refused scheme
um hopefully this will assist
members in understanding the the
alterations that have been
being put forward um as regards
this element of the scheme um the
semi-detached properties as you'll be
able to see
have been reduced in width and the
detached dwellings have been reduced in
height and width as well as being
repositioned
next slide please
so moving on to some photo montages of
the site this is
um looking in a southerly direction from
the access track
so the existing pig stars on the left
hand side of the track would be retained
as part of the scheme
and used for ancillary residential
purposes
the existing stone walls would be
retained as you can see throughout the
site the farm track would be resurfaced
with a porous resin bonded gravel
in the center of the image you can
clearly see the same detached dwellings
that would be proposed these dwellings
would in effect replace the existing
dutch barn
next slide please
so this slide again it's another
computer generated image of course
um and shows one of the key views into
the site from the countryside to the
south
the proposals show the converted
threshing barn on the right hand side
side of the built form
[Music]
and it also shows the proposed
additional dwellings
within the site as alluded to and the
introduction officers
do consider that there would be some
harm by virtue of the scale and massing
of these buildings in green belt and
heritage terms
that being said the benefits that have
been identified arising
from the comprehensive redevelopment of
the site
including um the restoration of of
existing buildings of merit um officers
are cons
are of the view that the harm identified
would be outweighed by i said benefits
next slide please
again another computer generated image
which shows the
yard of the threshing barn with the
detached dwellings
in the background with the ancillary
building which would have been restored
it is intervening in the in between
those spaces
um this image hopefully provides some
context in terms of how these buildings
will relate to one another
next slide please
moving on to photos of the application
site
this photo is taken from the southern
edge of the site looking out towards the
open countryside
just on the left of that image you can
see the riding arena
associated with the former equestrian
use of the site
next slide please
taken from a very similar spot the um
next photo is looking in a northerly
direction
um back into the conservation area in
the built
form of the uh collection of buildings
looking left to right you can see the
bungalow and the dutch barn which are
earmarked for removal
and beyond that are a number of historic
buildings which would be
converted and repaired as part of the
wider scheme this includes a threshing
barn on the right of the image
as you can see it there next slide
please
again a bit more detail on the threshing
barn and some of the other
historic buildings the more utilitarian
aspect of that building would be removed
leaving the
historic building to be converted
next slide please
again this is the dutch barn which is
earmarked for removal
and historic farm buildings which would
be restored as part of the development
proposals
next slide please
and a further build a picture of the
buildings to be restored
next slide please
this is a view from within the
application site looking towards the
existing farmhouse which is outside the
application site to the north the land
in the foreground that you can see would
comprise the rear gardens for the
proposed semi-detached dwellings
next slide please nikki
again from a similar point just this is
looking back towards the
central track running through the
application site
next slide please
and again from a similar point within
the site looking at some of the
historic farm buildings that would be uh
would be restored as part of the
development proposals
uh next slide please uh this is the
dutch barn which would be
earmarked for removal the semi-detached
properties would
broadly sit on a on the same foot
a similar footprint or in that location
rather
next slide please again this is the
dutch barn with a lean to aspect which
will also be removed
next slide please um
this is a view from within the
application
site which hopefully gives a
understanding of the character of the
of the site with the um the existing
buildings
um this is the threshing barn which is a
mark for conversion to a single dwelling
as you can see it benefits from a number
of openings at its
principal elevation which would be
utilized in that conversion a number of
the ancillary buildings that you can see
in the foreground and the the timber
stables would be removed as part of the
application as well next slide please
um another um photograph from
the access track looking in a southerly
direction
um you can just see the pig stars on the
left and again it gives you an
indication of the
the current character of that aspect of
the site next slide please
um a very similar picture just taken
from a few yards back from the last one
but this gives you a
bigger understanding of the the context
of the site in this location you've got
the pig stars on the left hand side
stone walls throughout the site in the
center of that image you can see the
dutch barn which would be
removed and would as mentioned
previously
[Music]
be the site of the semi-detached
properties roughly next slide please
and this site shows the gated access
sorry this photo shows the gated access
to the site
on the right hand side as you can see it
and the bridal way continuing
on from the from the lane in the center
of the picture
next slide please um this
photo is taken looking in another
direction of
cartilage lane um it's
um you can see clearly there's dwellings
on the left hand side of the
of the image grade 2 star listed
hall on the right the hall situated
approximately 75 meters
to the north of the access of the
application site
and the final two slides that we're
going to move on to
show the junction of cartilage lane and
milford lane
this particular image is looking in a
northerly direction and i think we've
just moved on to the
second image which is looking uh to the
south
and that concludes the presentation
thank you
[Music]
thank you colin and i'm going to move on
to the speakers
and we have six speakers for this
application we'll start with the
objectives
i'll take them in the order that i have
in front of me and the first one is
maureen turner
hello hello are you there oh there you
are
you have three minutes maureen um when
you're ready
okay thank you good afternoon chairman
and members
we refused the planning application for
virtually the same development
in july 2020 and since that time minor
amendments have been made
which tinker around the edges but failed
to change the fundamental policy
objections the planning officer accepts
the development
is contrary to green belt policies the
only changes
are the width of the houses the number
is the same and while the width of some
of those houses is reduced
they have been slightly increased in
depth and two have been increased in
height
the very special circumstances put
forward are only to ensure the historic
buildings are retained
however however planning look case law
requires
this form of enabling development where
the proposals are contrary to planning
policy
to be supported by financial appraisals
to show that without the new housing
the development of the historic
buildings is unviable
no such appraisal has been submitted
document relic
relates to enabled sorry enabling
development yet
it has been ignored and that's the
documents
the historic buildings can be retained
and developed as houses without the new
housing
and i'm sure would comply with all your
policies the public interest can be
preserved without the new housing car
parking remains an issue
to which the highways department have
registered an objection to the shortfall
only 11 spaces are available for six
dwellings some of which are unusable and
there's no visitor parking
the access to and from willful lane is
already dangerous
without further development highways
have not objected because they've been
misled into thinking
the equestrian center could reopen no
such equestrian center ever existed as
the former owner of the site has
confirmed
the proposals are urban in character and
are not appropriate for an edge a
village like this
development remains contrary to green
belt policy with no justifiable
very special circumstances it does not
preserve
or enhance the conservation area or the
natural environment
the developers have launched an appeal
against the previous refusal
and if you approve this application you
will find it impossible to make a sound
case to defend that
appeal you will probably end up with a
scheme you have refused being allowed
on that appeal please stick by your
previous decisions
don't be misled and refuse this
application for the same reasons
thank you very much thank you
thank you and the next speaker is mike
dawson
oh i beg your pardon first of all are
there any questions for
miss turner no okay
moving on to mike dawson
mr dawson are you here
have you got me yes you have three
minutes
the first thing the most important thing
that i want to say is that this
is still this proposed application is
still
an inappropriate over development of a
conservation site
this is still an inappropriate
appropriate over development of a green
belt area
this site is was is within the sheffield
greenbelt
and the national planning policy
framework
and states very clearly quote
inappropriate development is by
definition
harmful to the greenbelt and should not
be approved except in very special
circumstances
the buildings that are now there are not
special circumstances and not
needed to be saved to allow a mini
housing estate to be built
we are then concerned about the weight
being applied in the conclusions which
has led to a
recommended traditional approval
particularly around the repeated
assertions of officers that this
application will somehow
save existing buildings that is a flawed
framing of this application
and as local residents we would ask that
the committee disregard this assertion
for which no proof is offered in making
their final determination
the size bulk and height of each of
these new designs will have a negative
impact on the beautiful countryside
they do not blend into the green belt
area but actually stand out
as an eyesore and a blight on the
landscape they will let they will be a
visual intrusion of this
conservation area and greenbelt area
officers have conceded in the summary
that the openness of the greenbelt is
not preserved by
this application and sizable buildings
which are relatively conspicuous
are being proposed the officers also
accept
there will be harm to the local area
from a visual perspective
that is contrary to the nppf and to the
local
neddc policies
also the access road is not suitable for
more traffic especially with the farm
traffic
it is narrow and the junction where
cartridge lane and milford lane meet
is an awful junction where car drivers
can't see both ways
unless they pull well into the road
increased traffic will increase the
likelihood of accidents and injury
if the committee takes a step back it is
clear that this
application and its size bulk proposed
replacement
impact on green belt impact on the
conservation area
location and approach does not align
with either the spirit
or the framework rules on these
important issues
based on that alone this application
should be rejected
thank you thank you um
i don't know why but i've suddenly got a
hand appear up on our screen about the
council chamber
not sure if you can get rid of that i'll
have a look into that for you chad
thank you are there any questions for mr
dawson
no thank you mr dawson the next speaker
is
maureen greenland
hello can you see me hello yes you have
three minutes
yes good afternoon last year as you know
a very similar application to this one
was unanimously rejected by councillors
as being an inappropriate development of
a greenbelt
and harmful to the intrinsic character
of a conservation area nothing has
changed since then
except for very minor modifications to
the proposed houses
the farm is still in a conservation area
and the green belt hasn't moved
the case for very special circumstances
that would allow building on the green
belt is dubious and insubstantial
it's invalid because there's no evidence
to support the notion
that the only way to restore the
historic buildings is by building
new houses both our planning consultant
eric
telford and lee rowley mp have strongly
emphasized this point
there are no financial or practical
details to show
how it could be achieved or the extent
of the reserve
the the renovations or what the public
benefits might be
other serious objections have been
glossed over in the planning offices
report
in particular the legal status of the
footpath
and the implications for walkers if it
became a road
the incongruous style of the proposed
houses and their elevated position
the inadequate parking spaces and the
lack of extra space
for additional vehicles to maneuver and
park
the dangerous blind junction
on the road to and from the farm
difficult access within the farm along a
bendy
single track and upward up
up an awkward slope and
the proposal for street lighting where
cartilage lane
residents have voted for darkness
the old farm is not the place from any
suburb complete with hedges
gravel paths and probably trampolines
and summer houses
increased traffic is a real worry who
knows what
other further developments there might
be in the future
what uses might be found for the
renovated buildings
there's been no consultation with local
people and no sympathy for their fears
this scheme is ill-advised and
impractical
above all the plan to build on the green
belt
is unjustifiable it has to be firmly
refused
as it was before 30 seconds remain thank
you
thank you do we have any questions
no thank you dr green that's
it yes thank you that's it you got off
lightly
and the final speakers of the objectives
are thomas greenson
chair your technical issue which you
mentioned should be resolved now
thank you it is
good afternoon everybody good afternoon
you have three minutes
thank you um i'm here in my capacity
as chairman of holmesville football
broadway society
it is necessary to clarify and legalize
the status of footpath 26
previous comments by walking groups have
expressed concerns
which have not been resolved
historically the route from south
to north did not pass through the whole
farm
but veered eastwards to meet right away
53.
about four decades ago the previous
owner
now deceased blocked the footpath right
away junction
and instead allowed walkers to pass
straight through the farm
on the track to the northern gate this
footpath
has now been signposted by the council
and is frequently used as a walking
route
through the countryside between carthage
and milford
under the proposed plan the farm track
will become a hard surface road
used by potential residents visitors and
service vehicles
the future use of the footpath must be
discussed and
considered the legal position of the
present group needs to be regularized
and if necessary designated before
further action
is taken on the planning application
indeed who would buy the threshing bomb
when their solicitor points out that the
public right away
goes right through the middle i'm
guessing about 20 years ago
in gosforth valley it was all hell let
loose
but it was pointed out that houses have
been built on a public right away
it took years to sort out a already
residents were
able to sell their houses and were in
fear they could be
demolished thank you for listening
thank you are there any questions
i just have one mr green regarding
footpath 26
it runs through the threshing barn if
you look at the map properly is that
correct
yes so as the barney's there people
can't walk through it now
so has it been uh moved officially
the footpath has never been moved
officially no the uh
talking to the people at matt like the
footpath officer mr mountain
he is aware of this anomaly but i'm not
sure he knows what to do about it
but would anyone buy the threshing barn
hands up do you know when the barn was
put up because obviously the footpath
must have been there before the barn
so i don't know okay thank you
any further questions no
thank you we'll move on thank you we'll
move on to the next speakers and then
the agent carl taylor excuse me chair
it'll be
susan crowley who's uh in it speaking in
his absence
oh okay thank you thank you
there hello hi thank you um
you're ready thank you chair i do
apologize carl
um the applicant's landscape consultant
hasn't been able to join us today
so i'm going to be reading from his
statement and bear with me while i pick
through it
um in response to members previous
concerns about
uh impact on the landscape and visual
impact more broadly
um the applicant commissioned the input
of a landscape consultant
and who's prepared a landscape visual
impact assessment
which has supported the planning
application and the purpose of this
report really was to set out the extent
to which the proposals would impact upon
the landscape and visual amenity of the
surrounding landscape in the village
um it was put together we must stress
following the latest national
and technical guidance to offer as
transparent and objective a description
of these potential effects as is
possible
um carl would like to stress that this
landscaping visual impact appraisal was
developed from desktop-based research
site visits and in discussion with
related disciplines such as our heritage
consultant
in terms of overall impact carl accepts
that landscape effects can be adverse
neutral or beneficial but in this case
his assessment is that the change and
effects are beneficial
primarily due to the removal of
detracting structures
the restoration of historic buildings
and the enhancement of their settings
through the removal
of the detracting neighboring structures
and through the sensitive nature of the
proposals
and the design of the new buildings
within an urban arrangement that retains
and respects the linear nature of the
original farmstead and the roots through
and around it so in terms of landscape
impact then
the summary is the effects are
beneficial
in terms of visual impact it's been
determined that the edge of settlement
location of the site its wooded
character and the undulating nature of
the topography restricts the visual
envelope of it
and views are therefore often
substantially filtered by layers of
field trees
woodland and hedgerows or else blocked
by existing built form
in that context it's been decided
by a landscape expert that the proposals
are considered as a visual change which
is
beneficial securing the visual amenity
attached to the threshing barn
the cart shed the pigsty and other stone
buildings to be retained within the farm
group
it is also considered by our expert
beneficial through the removal of modern
and detracting elements allowing the
remaining heritage buildings to appear
uncompromised the proposed additional
buildings will not interfere with views
currently possible
and will maintain the aspect from the
public
footpath network in terms of impact on
greenbelt
the expert has concluded the proposals
lie within an existing area of
development where both physical and
visual amenities will be contained
within aries already established as
developed the purposes of 30 seconds
remain
the purposes of the green belt will be
protected and the restoration of
buildings and land will answer purpose 5
of said greenbolt
encouraging the recycling and
regeneration of land
in all the conclusion is the effects are
beneficial from a landscape visual
impact
assessment thank you
thank you i have a question for you
considering this was refused originally
and we've heard from residents
were the residents never considered when
you've gone back to look at this new
proposal
yeah thank you for that question we did
go out to public consultation by the
parish
council ahead of submitting the former
planning application and i think we set
that out in our statement in support of
the
submission that's the parish council i'm
talking about the residents the
residents that were going to have the
the impact
on the development the people that live
closest to it
no we didn't make contact ahead of the
planning application going in but as far
as i'm aware they have been consulted
during the planning application
determination process by the case
officer
thank you councillor foster
uh thank you chair uh mark foster member
for call aston
um uh hello mrs crowley um
yeah my question is about uh when you
spoke about the
the impact on the green belt uh when you
look at what our officers
have put in the report it's still
considered inappropriate development as
you probably know
um and that is only acceptable
if we have got the very special
circumstances
now the very special circumstances are
still and they're only given
in once one just one sentence in this
whole report
by our officers which is public benefits
by saving this important historic farm
group
now there's no more in in here about
that
other than that one sentence and that
that was the same last july
we had no explanation on that whatsoever
and
one of the objectives dr greenland
pointed out that that very same
fact and i you know uh
without prejudging this until i've heard
all uh representations
i've stole up to now got the same view
that i had before last july because this
has not changed on this element of it
another scale and message changed and i
know
the substantial harm part has changed
because the officers said reduce harm
i understand that but when it comes to
the specific part about public benefits
by saving this important historic farm
group
would you like to elaborate on that a
little and explain what those public
benefits
are um thank you councillor if i could
just defer to our heritage consultant on
that
councillor foster because mel morris is
going to speak after me and mel will set
out the whole argument around public
benefits
and preservation of the building group
um i would just like to stress with
reference the
enabling argument again mel will talk to
you about that it isn't a requirement in
this instance to go through that
exercise
we did specify to the case officer and
planning in general that we would be
happy to submit a viability report
in support of the application it wasn't
felt to be necessary
um nor was it a requirement for
validation in this instance but i would
like to defer to mel
mel morris will provide the sort of the
the expertise i think you're looking for
in order to answer that question with
reference public benefits would that be
okay
i appreciate that and i'll wait for uh
the heritage expert but you know you did
mention the impact on the green belt so
that's why the question was relating to
that
yeah yes the impact on the green belt in
landscape terms
is not felt to be other anything other
than
beneficial uh given the context that
we're currently working with
and that's the the position we put
forward in our case to offices now
officers have drawn a different judgment
um in that regard we're comfortable with
our
um assessment on it and we've appointed
a landscape expert
to evidence that position ahead of
putting another application in
now in the absence of evidence on the
part of the local authority to the
country
um you know we have an expert that's
supporting this position
an independent expert um who's who has
drawn this conclusion that the overall
impact isn't
harmful in fact it is beneficial both in
landscape effect terms
and in terms of visual impact so um i i
i can't i can't speak for your offices
we have to disagree with them on that
point given our expert evidence
thank you for that
are there any further questions
no thank you miss candy and we'll move
on to the next speaker mel morris
mr morris are you there yes thank you
sorry
you're up there mikayla right three
minutes
thank you very much and good afternoon
everybody
with this site it is important that we
don't forget
what the baseline position is the
baseline is that we have 20th century
development
on the west side of the farmstead part
of the 20th century farm
as well as the livery buildings to the
southeast
the proposed development lies almost
entirely within the conservation area
and the area has been historically
developed as part of the farmstead
the dutch barn is part of the farm
i do not agree therefore that the
principle of development
in this west part of the site is
inherently harmful to the character of
the conservation area
the existing development around the
buildings is harmful to the conservation
area in a number of ways
including the fact that it is
inappropriate
with its use of alien materials brick
and render
concrete block work and its sprawling
form
and the fact that it obscures the
original appearance
of the threshing barn both to the north
and the south
following the refusal of the previous
application i looked at the design
with the architect to address many of
the concerns of the committee
the alignment of the four bed houses has
been set
further back on site this has made a big
difference
the revised scheme for the westernmost
building
is 2.5 meters further back on the site
and by changing the largest five-bed
dwelling to a four-bed dwelling
and by removing the garage we've made a
major reduction in the scale of this
on the western perimeter of the site at
the highest point
we also reduced the scale and eaves
height of this
and the other dwellings we were also
able to reduce the scale of the
four bed dwelling by lowering the eaves
floor-to-ceiling heights maintaining the
traditional roof pitch
and we also created a step in the
development
with a single story element which
reveals more of the southern stable
in the principal view and which creates
more penetrative views
through the western part of the
development
we're now using local stone for all of
the walls
which will be laid in narrow courses
rather than large blocks
in conjunction with stone lintels and
sills
the public benefits are that the
original farm buildings which are
important historically
and make a con major contribution to the
character of the conservation area
30 seconds remain extremely vulnerable
um
will be repaired and our scheme will
cross subsidize this
um and the con with the conversion of
the threshing bond
the removal of the obtrusive development
and the changes
as a whole reduces the scale of the
development
better reveals the cluster and
suppresses heights
creates more steps with a reduction
in volume of about 25
thank you thank you do we have any
questions
no thank you very much oh counselor
yeah yeah all right naturally here chair
the uh
the uh the description of the public
benefits yes
so in terms of the um national planning
policy framework
um one of the um one of the criteria is
that if we have
if you identify a level of harm
then a public benefit is to create
optimum viable use
so when we're looking at um the
threshing ball which is a
17th century late 17th century building
we're looking at the buildings around
the site
i've looked quite carefully at what is
the optimum viable use of those and how
this scheme
can address the the public benefit of
bringing them back into use
so it's creating a viable use for
buildings which are important
in the conservation area that's the
primary public benefit
we're securing the future of of a group
of buildings which would otherwise
um collapse they have no economic use as
they stand
so they would eventually just collapse
over time
because there's no in incentive for the
owner to spend money on them
so that is the public benefit and
ultimately you're finding a use for a
building
which would otherwise have no
economic okay thank you
are there any further questions
thank you thank you
before we move on i'll just ask alan to
remind us all about motions and then
i'll open the floor for debate
thank you yes just bear with me sure
yes uh just to remind members again that
a motion must be moved and seconded
before a vote is taken
if an amendment to a motion is moved and
seconded then that amendment will be
voted on first
if an ocean is to be moved which goes
against officer recommendations then the
member who's moved the motion must give
the reason for doing so
the reasons for moving a motion against
officer recommendations
should comprise the relevant planning
issues and be supported by the evidence
as necessary if a motion to reject
officer recommendation
fails or in other words is not passed
that doesn't mean to say that the
recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision through a further motion
in favor of the recommendations or
another course of action
this will need to be approved by the
committee through another vote
in terms of the timings of the motions
as mentioned before
these should be moved and seconded after
the committee has heard and read
and discussed the evidence before us
the chair will indicate when this point
has been reached
and then will invite motions to be put
members will be reminded of this by the
clerk if they wish to move
a motion before then thank you chair
thank you well i'm going to open the
floor for debate
um i'm going to lead by saying i am
rather disappointed
in the proposal that's been put before
us
because to me there doesn't seem a huge
great deal of change
um but i'm going to keep my mind open
until i see now councillor armitage
council elliott and councillor [ __ ]
have all got their hands up
excuse me just before you reach that um
um would you want to um
give the planning officer or rather the
planning um officer manager the
opportunity to answer any questions
definitely
thank you chair
colin are you there
okay are there any questions for
colin from the members
councillor elliot
you're on mute peter
thanks thanks chair colin just a
question really
i i've listened quite extensively to the
heritage lady
and the people who live in the lab
and i can't see a great deal of
difference in the scaling and massin
that would change any of my opinion from
page 25 where i was saying it's
primarily in the green belt and it would
cause substantial arm and it's
considered
for the mppfts2 that it's when looked at
the whole
it doesn't meet his criteria can you can
you just give us a bit of information
that's made you
change your mind on this because i just
can't i can't see it
um officers sorry just to clarify uh
council elliot officers haven't
changed their minds in effect as the um
you may recall the application was
recommended for approval
um both back in march and june of last
year i think it was deferred in march
and then subsequently
it was refused against offer officer
recommendation at the june committee so
in our conclusions in this um assessment
we're in effect
saying that there are improvements which
i think you refer to
albeit you're suggesting that they're
minimal improvements in your opinion
um so as regards our professional
opinion and
and the overall officer opinion that
remains largely unchanged um in terms of
the overall
conclusions but we do we do consider
that this scheme
is an improvement on the previously
refused scheme by members but
um as suggested that was um that was
recommended for approval as well
i i just find it strange that a year or
more
back we were sat there this if you
looked at the photos you can see a load
of lights in the wall that leads around
the drive
and we were discussing how how the we'd
have problems with the
lights around the drive we needed them
shrouded because
the the people who live up there were
saying that that it
was intrusive in the darkness and now
we're looking at a scheme for probably
another
half a dozen houses and a lot more like
pollution
course we've had to look at the
application on its individual merits and
this is a wider redevelopment of the
entire site so
as us alluded to previously there are
benefits that we've identified and our
heritage consultant has
identified as as as outweighing
the harm um certainly in heritage terms
and
and we've identified that that would
represent very special circumstances in
the green belt so i'd probably
um have to suggest that we'd have to
look at this application obviously on
its merits i understand
the point you're making about um
sensitive lighting in in
in this locality and and that in
isolation but
of course we need to look at the um this
scheme in its entirety and that's what
we've endeavored to do
yeah the only reason i bring that one up
colin is because i saw the picture in
the wall and the lights that were still
there
and it just made me smile thinking we're
thinking about putting a half a dozen
new houses up
when only a year or so ago we were
discussing that those lights should be
shrouded because
they were a light bullet and it's just
unbelievable to me but thanks very much
for your answer colin
welcome
are there any further questions
thank you colin okay i will open the
floor now
for debate
council [ __ ]
sorry about that problem um i'm in
complete agreement with councillor
elliot
and all the objectors um and
i i cannot understand like you say there
is there's very
little change um
8.15 states that it's a very valuable
historic group of farm buildings
and i just i kind of understand how
it can be beneficial to have modern
houses
put in between historic farm buildings
and the event beneficial to a
conservation area i'm also very
concerned about the footpath situation
as we have
something extremely similar in fact
virtually the same
in our own village where a farm building
was sold
for to be up changed into housing which
it
has been and the new resident is
really causing us an awful lot of
problems with the footpath
refusing to let people through etc and
we've had patrick mountain from
county council on to it since um
march last year so it's a year
so i would please consider that because
it will happen there will be problems
trade if you get people living there
they are not going to want people
walking
past their houses so i'm very concerned
about that as well
but i do believe that this goes against
policy be
11 to preserve and enhance the character
of the conservation
area i just don't understand how this
can possibly
do that thank you
thank you councillor foster
i think there might have been others
before me but i'm happy to go
yep okay thanks chair uh yeah for me the
only
changes i can see in this from the one
we had last year is the scale of massing
um and when we look at the three reasons
we knocked it back we refused
permission last year those three reasons
we got on page 25
the scale and massing are only mentioned
in two and three
uh so for me they still stand uh
there is a very slight change but it's
still
uh substantial it's not mentioned in
uh in the first reason the scale of mass
in there that talks about the
uh the openness and the green belt and
the inappropriate development
we've still got this clusters uh
inappropriate development
and although the officers have stated
that there's reduced harm
that harm is still substantial and
that's in my view
i know it's not the view of the uh uh
the applicant and the agent but there is
still
um a reduced harm and it is still a
substantial harm
uh when we go on then to the reasons we
refused it and
um in that first part it talks about the
very special circumstances
that are needed to outweigh the harm now
it's still my view
that that's not there the public
benefits by saving this important
historic farm group they are still not
they're still not met in my view so that
first one still stands
and as for the others two and three the
reasons we gave they still stand as well
uh without going through all the
policies because they're all there
enlisted him
in front of us it's still substantial
harm
or be reduced so all those three reasons
for every uh refusing that that stood
last year still stand today
in my view thanks chair
thank you councillor armitage
uh thank you chair uh well i think uh
uh council fosterers sort of
underlined everything which i uh
consider about this site
we turned it down last time there's very
little difference
i mean how can we justify uh
four new dwellings uh in the green belt
you know it will
cause substantial harm it doesn't matter
how you try and dress it
up make it slightly smaller make it a
bit
taller and all the rest of it it is
substantial
harm and its goals against gs2
uh as regarding uh the uh
it's in the shadow it's in the
conservation area as well
and this should this should be uh you
know looked after
and it's harm to the local pub uh public
and the
amenity value i cannot see quite
frankly how putting four new houses up
is going to increase the immunity value
uh of the rest of the site yes i can see
that uh these uh older buildings
can be converted uh and they should be
uh preserved but not putting all these
new ones in
uh the older buildings were there before
the green belt was even thought about
uh so they won't cause much harm even if
they are converted but
as it stands at the moment this uh
this application is basically the same
as uh
we had before and i'll come to the same
conclusion
thank you council shipment
yes chair um i i agree with cancer
amateur actually i think
had come to council to the planning
committee
and said we want to convert the existing
um historic buildings
you know they looked at exactly how i
did it on this picture to be honest i
would be absolutely supporting this
i think trying to restore those
buildings
and then build four brand new spanking
new houses next to them
i think it just detracts away from the
reason you're actually trying to save
the historic ones in the first place
so as far as i'm concerned based on the
reasons that council
foster was listed out earlier um i think
it's a no from me okay
thank you are there any other comments
counselor barry i think most people have
actually said it nothing's really
changed from the planning application
that came in last year
um to say that this is going to enhance
it and be better for the public is
is a fast because putting those brand
new buildings up which are going to
stand higher
than the lane they're going to stick out
like a sore thumb for anybody that's
coming anywhere near there
let alone coming up from the upper side
of the footpath
so i don't see how they can say it's for
the public benefit i mean to me this is
just an economic benefit for the person
that owns the land
that wants to get the most out of it as
he can do um
and the properties that renovate the old
ones that you know there's enough there
for you to do and to make properties
viable and we all know even if you can't
do them all that as we walk through our
countryside we see lots of dilapidated
stone bombs
that have been left and they become part
of the feature of our landscape
within the green belt so let's not think
that brand new and
smart looking things are everything that
needs to be in the green in the green
belt we need to be preserving what we've
got
and the properties that are proposed
here are not suitable
um in exactly the same way as it weren't
suitable when it came before as in the
first place
um so i think you know i think everybody
here has had that
discussion with themselves about whether
anything's changed or not
nothing's changed um it's still
an eyesore in the greenbelt so i just
think that you know i mean for me i
think we need to move to
the vote or to whatever but i i would
definitely recommend going against
officers recommendations
thank you if there's no other comment
i'll ask oh
councillor foster thank you chair yeah
when i'm looking at the uh
the reasons we're refusing for last time
uh one two three i can't think
uh if i were to put a motion
to refuse this i can't think i would
change this and i'd ask
other members of the committee to look
at those reasons and see what more we
could add to that
to make this clear
uh because we were asked last time to
give our opinion on this
uh we were asked to consider uh
if the special circumstances had been
met and we said they hadn't
and it's come back again so i'd like to
make this clear to officers exactly
where we stand here as a
as a committee so i'd like our offices
to listen to this as well as the agents
uh on our opinion and i'm wondering if
we can add anything in this
so i'd like to put that to other members
thank you chair
counselor announcement oh cheers
thank you god ross here all right carry
on
i was just gonna say actually just to i
think we need to object on the things
that we are really bothered about here
rather than trying to list as many
things
as we possibly can get on there together
you know i think if we just stick to the
stuff that
we see as a problem with this which to
me
is the fact that we are building in the
green belt with new houses
uh so is that uh ss10
ss9 i've got a few for your ross if you
need yeah i'm going to say because
then that message is clear we're happy
for them to be renovated
i assume we all are on that same
wavelength but
it's the fact that we're building new
houses in the green belt which to me is
the sticking point
okay thank you councillor elliot thanks
chair chair i think
i think uh my colleagues have said
exactly what
what's right already and and yes mark
mark's right it is a long list the
reason it was a long list last time is
because they were all the relevant
policies
that the application is pertaining to
gs2 of the local plan gs1 gs6 h12
be 11 we could carry on there they're
all the
they're all the relevant things that our
officers need to understand
us as a committee don't like it it's
basically
you know the agents and that are going
to call it up and say there's no harm to
the green belt of course they are
but for me sticking all those brand new
buildings there
on that that really stand up on the edge
of that
on the edge of that lane on the edge of
the bridle way overlooking the valley
of course they're going to be prominent
and of course they're gonna
for me infringing the green belt and and
the
openness of the greenback so all those
policies that are there are still
relevant
thank you councillor armitage
i think it was pointed out last time
that
uh and also uh when we
go against officers recommendation with
the various reasons
it's always uh adrian has always
advocated
that we use the strongest ones uh
and i think uh with all due respect to
mark
on page 25 one two and three
are the strongest ones and we shall
stick with them
yeah councillor barry yeah i think
you know when i said about voted against
officers recommendations it is to stick
with all
those things that we had in the first
place because they are the strongest
arguments that we've got and i think
they are still extremely relevant
now nothing's changed enough from those
three
to make me feel any different about this
application
so you know like i said i i still go
against officers recommendations
carrying forward with
exactly what we had before
thank you okay any other comments at
this point
richard
yeah thank you that's clearly a very
strong um
overall view from uh members but um in
their minds nothing has changed
and i think that because that is uh the
view
then just to really uh agree with one or
two of the members
what they said there then i i'd agree
that um if nothing has changed
then in their minds then nothing should
change in the reasons for refusal
either and i think um you know
looking wider field and starting to
introduce other things
would only just lead into difficulties
and potentially undermining
the the strength that you feel there is
in those previous reasons for refusal
thank you everybody finished
yep alan would you just like to run
through um
moving a promotion well we've we've just
done that
uh and what i would suggest now um you
do move to the point where we actually
get
a motion um before us uh
as things stand you've yet to open so
i'm assuming you're opening if the
floor for that now yes thank you we've
heard everything we're going to hear
today and
regarding recommendations etc i'm now
opening the floor for
a motion chair i'll quite happily move
the recommendation that we go against
officer recommendation
for the self same reasons i said earlier
everything in 5.2
and the things listed on the three
points above it on page 25.
so gs1 gs6 h12
be 11. and the whole the whole list
i think even richard has just said the
the right thing
you know it's what we thought last time
and nothing
significantly changed to change our
minds so why would we change our minds
on the things we got last time around
i'll second it's okay we've got a second
to hear counselor barry yeah i was going
to second
um that motion okay um
keeping it as it was as strong as it was
in the first place
okay so essentially venture is it to
go against officer recommendations um
for the reasons
originally used by the committee when it
actually turned down the original
application
earlier in the year yes is that the
essence of the members
yes that's it for me alan for sure yeah
okay we'll move to the vote
their members is clearly safe or against
or abstain to go against
the application counselor armitage
or counselor barry
or casa cooper ball
that's elliott poor castle mark foster
or cancer rough oh
and cancer shipment or
chair with 12 votes four zero against
zero abstentions
that motion was carried thank you thank
you all we'll move
on to the next item of the agenda that's
the planning appeals lodged and
determined
richard are you going to lead on this
i think we just move and note them don't
we share
unless there's anything richard wants to
say richard can you hear us
you're a mute richard yep i can hear you
i'm just um picking up the uh
the agenda to see if there's anything
really that needs to be
mentioned about it i mean you can see um
what has been uh submitted i mean
that there's there is a date um
uh already set for the um
informal hearing in relation to
the first refusal of um
it isn't it's not on there it's already
been through the system i think become
uh for uh curtis lane
which is 18th of may so the the first
refuge the first scheme will be
considered an informal hearing
then um whether the applicants ask the
inspector to consider
the amendments that are considered today
or whether they go um
pull out for the main
for the first proposal remains to be
seen um but
i i've got no other um i mean
clearly there's new appeals in there
which are um
information um the only two decisions
that we've had
um are there um one which committee
refused
or both of which committee um refused
and seemed to have gone through the
system fairly quickly because of fairly
recent ones but um i've got nothing more
to add on
on any of them it's really just there
for your information
thank you so we'll just make those as
noted
thank you i have no matters of urgency
so thank you all for your attendance
this afternoon and have a good weekend
thank you thank you
you